vu du ciel on peut voir l'ampleur des
dégâts des centaines de maisons ont été
éventrées ce sont les habitants qui
déblé à la main les grava des conditions
difficiles et pourtant plusieurs escapés
ont pu être sauvés et lui aussi s'est
tout de suite mobilisé pour tenter
d'organiser l'aide au sinistr Jamel de
Bou est à Marrakech il a donné son sang
et salué à l'IM solidarité des habitants
on
l'écoute je suis je suis très je je suis
très ému d'être
ici on a eu l'occasion de de voir un peu
toute cette solidarité elle est
incroyable faut la filmer faut la
transmettre faut voir j'aurais aimé vous
montrer la suite de ce zapping mais
malheureusement suite à la
démonétisation de notre chaîne zap télé
officielle cet été il nous est désormais
impossible de continuer à diffuser les
apps sur Youtube notre appel ayant été
rejeté mais rassurez-vous deux
possibilités s'offrent désormais à vous
pour ueer de voir les appctu les apptélé
et les appnet sur vos appareils
connectés première possibilité vous
rendre sur le site
zaptéé.fr
zapt.fr pour ceux qui auraient un peu de
mal à taper l'adresse du site dans leur
navigateur on vous a ajouté un lien
direct dans la description juste en
dessous comme d'habitude vous y
trouverez chaque jour dès 7h du matin le
Zap actu de zap télé entre 12h et 13h et
le zapnet à 18h deuxième possibilité
nous vous proposons de concevoir
vous-même vos propres zaing et pour cela
et parce qu'on est pas chez zap télé on
va vous montrer comment procéder tout
d'abord il vous faut une télévision qui
doit rester allumée en permanence le but
étant de ne rien rater de ce qui se
passe dans le petit écran ensuite vous
prenez vos CIN ordinateurs et vous les
programmez pour enregistrer un maximum
de chaînes une fois vos 250 heur de
programme enregistré
[Musique]
regardez-les lorsque vous repérez une
séquence digne d'être diffusée dans
votre zapping exportez-la et nommez-la
avec un titre unique et
explicite réitérez cette opération tout
au long de votre visionnage autant de
fois qu'il le faudra une fois les 250 he
de programme d rchet c'est comme ça
qu'on dit dans le jargon allumez votre
logiciel de montage et rangez vos
séquences dans l'ordre qui vous semble
le plus approprié rajouterz les mentions
légales titres production et logo et
Lanz l'export de votre vidéo voilà votre
zapping est prêt à être diffusé sur
Internet il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous
connecter à votre chaîne Youtube poster
votre vidéo vous rendre compte qu'il y a
un problème de droit d' retirez
l'extrait problématique de la timeline
sur votre logiciel de montage réexportez
votre zapping puis repostez-le sur
Youtube et voilà votre zapping est en
ligne prêt à être regardé par le plus
grand nombre et être commenté sans
concession par des internautes plus ou
moins à l'aise avec la gram mère sinon
je le rappelle vous avez toujours la
possibilité de vous rendre sur le site
zapté.fr c'est gratuit et il semble que
les premiers visiteurs soient déjà
totalement satisfaits j'ai huciné alors
à tout de suite j'espère sur zaptéé.fr
gros
bisous